whether fighting in World War 2 Vietnam
the distant future or the modern-day
fans have come to expect one thing when
they hear the word battlefield all-out
warfare in Omaha Visceral Games and dice
are teaming up to bring the all-out
warfare experience to a new setting the
war on crime in Omaha you will engage in
all-out criminal warfare as you fight to
serve and protect or serve yourself
battlefield has always been about
teamwork and playing with friends when
squad works together few games are as
fun or rewarding multiplayer modes in
Omaha are filled with tactical
coordination in mind whether you're
organizing a hostage rescue with SWAT or
staging an elaborate bank heist and cops
need backup and criminals need a crew
there has never been a greater need for
the teamwork and tactical gameplay than
Battlefield fans expect the all new
heist mode is all about the big score
while the robbers try to blow up in the
vault and make off of the loot the cops
are there to block their every escape
in rescue SWAT masterminds move in to
save hostages captured during a robbery
gone wrong hot wire has cops chasing car
thieves across huge open environments
players have to think fast and drive
even faster
blood money is a fast-paced battle over
a huge pile of money for the cops and
criminals fight to secure the cash and
take it back to their savings
no matter your play style or preferred
side of the law there is a multiplayer
mode for you
previously on Omaha well you say we bag
these guys and grab some lunch
after delivering amazing storytelling in
games like dead space the visceral team
aims to revitalize our single-player
campaign with Omaha our hero is Nick
Mendoza a young Miami detective who gets
caught up in his own personal struggle
between right and wrong cop and criminal
Nick embarks on a cross-country quest
seeking revenge against his once trusted
partners along a force that's nine point
nine million dollars worth of coke uh
what are you drugged Rain Man
come on let's leave it for the cops I'm
not letting cops take this surrounding
Nick is a rogue gallery of crooked cops
and colorful criminals from chatterbox
coke dealers to deranged billionaires I
want my laptop the Omaha campaign draws
influence from popular television cop
drama each level structured like an
episode cliffhangers and on
and those are bringing its characters to
life is an all-star cast and crew from
hit shows like justified the Americans
and house of cards on the gameplay side
our environments are wider and more open
than ever before an enemy AI has been
redesigned from ground up the result is
a story where episodes can be played
multiple times and in multiple ways
one of our key hallmarks is destruction
and Omaha takes this to the next level
by bringing it even closer to home
set in locations both glitzy and gritty
you'll visit American urban settings to
create mayhem shoot out the inside of a
subterranean growler blow up a gleaming
bank vault for last apart Los Angeles
car dealership the wide array of urban
environments is modern sexy and of
course highly destructible all of this
destruction and mayhem along with having
multiple levels and events affecting
maps and game play makes Omaha the most
visually diverse battlefield yet
Omaha will feature a full arsenal of
military-grade weapons and some new
fiction inspired weapons as well such as
sawed-off shotguns and tasers the core
of player customization and unique
expression is the use of gadgets single
player Nick's police scanner enables an
investigation mechanic that packs the
world with clues and reveals a second
layer to the story with your Maj and it
can also scan suspects for outstanding
warrants using the money he earns for
unlocks most importantly the scanner
helps players choose their play style
flash through guns blazing sneak pass
your group of guards or set up a sniper
position on the rooftops it's your game
it's your choice and multiplayer gadgets
take center stage zip lines and
grappling hooks can be used on any map
anywhere making for chaotic
unpredictable combat
hunting down campers has never been this
much fun you'll find it all only in
Omaha
of course it wouldn't be a battlefield
game without vehicles to pilot and drive
muscle cars police cruisers
counter-attack trucks boats planes and
farm choppers are just a few of the ways
Omaha players again amp up the fun in
both multiplayer and singleplayer
race across the map to back up your
friends make roadkill out of enemies hop
on a motorcycle with loot strapped on
your back and blow past the cops vehicle
gameplay in Omaha is fresh fast and
intense don't worry
knocking a chopper out of the sky is
still one of the greatest thrills hand
gaming a new world with new levels of
freedom and new ways to play Omaha
brilliantly brings the cops and
criminals fantasy to life so get ready
to engage in all-out criminal warfare
whether you're a battlefield veteran or
it's your first time on the beat
you